hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round six of this
year's fide candidates tournament uh
it's tamara java versus rihard rapport
and as you guys have requested you would
like to see uh some more footage before
the before the actual game uh here is a
video a subscriber sent me some uh a
couple of days ago but i thought i'd
leave it if i'm going to show a game
between rajabo and rapport uh it is a
video of the two of them arriving in a
taxi i think it's from the chess.com
youtube channel uh uh not sure about
that but i'm pretty sure it is uh so
here's only a small fragment of it uh so
we can enjoy the game a little bit
better so there you see uh attacks
nicely arriving in here
and a job of uh are coming out of the
taxi so this is incredible footage um
definitely chess history right there
this will be remembered for a long time
and also ding is in there
so only improves the video uh so hope
you guys enjoyed that and also uh here
is a nice photo of the two of them uh
before the actual game okay the two
moves on the board but uh let's enjoy
that for a second as well as usual if
you guys can spot anything out of the
ordinary and the photos do uh you know
do you mention it uh
there are so many of you so um i'm
pretty sure we we could figure something
out i mean there's always something
wrong with the photos we just have to
figure out what it is so if you manage
to spot it do share so everyone else can
enjoy it as well now getting back to the
game rajavo has the white pieces and he
opens with pawn to e4
rapport replies with c5 the sicilian
defense knight f3 e6 and now d4 striking
in the center captures captures in the
knight to c6 going for the taimano
variation of the sicilian knight to c3
we have a6 in here uh a job of captures
we have knight captures b captures and
queen to d3 another very rare line uh
but uh rapper not very impressed he just
uh strikes in the center with the d5 if
you can do that in the sicilian you
should always do that
uh queen to g3 uh hindering the
development of the dark square bishop
but again rapper not very impressed he
just pushes h5 wants to kick away the
queen with h4 so arab rajab of stops
this and now pawn the d4 chasing away
the knight knight back to b1 uh you
could also play knight to d1 it was
tried in the game at dinchenko versus
mosses and he won a game with knight to
d1 but here knight to b1 is played
knights to f6 and now pawn to e5 now uh
we have to move the knight somewhere the
knight is either coming to e4 or to g4
uh and uh also knight to g4 was played
and uh andre king lost the game to tavel
mir
last year in defeat a world cup with
knight to g4 so here knight to e4 by
rapport and now queen to f3 as the queen
is attacked and we enter a very
well-known game uh between none other
than maxim vashilagrav indianapolis uh
that was played yes last year in the uh
grand chester uh croatia it was a rapid
event and the game ended in a draw but
in that game uh of course it went a
little bit different but uh the game
continues in the exact same way so queen
to d5 uh like uh nipple played in
croatia uh bishop to d3 threatening to
pick up the knight and pawn uh bishop to
b4 check we have king to f1 not worrying
about castling and now uh pawn to f5 we
have to defend our knight he captures an
f6 with check and now knight captures
offering a queen trade and in that game
do we mention mvl versus nipponishi c3
was played but here
uh rajab goes for bishop to g6 with
check and it seems like a move you would
play in a bullet game uh so you know
it's it's a move you play without
thinking uh because you prevent black
from castling and the black king now has
to find a square but where do you go if
you go to e7 then bishop g5 at some
point could be very strong so here uh
rapport plays king to d7 and this just
looks really weird
and not only is your bishop completely
blocked in by your pawns but now your
king is basically upon also blocking
your light square bishop so this is uh
it definitely doesn't look like
something that should be possible
however now in the era of engines
everything is possible uh so here we
have uh bishop to g5 again c3 uh does
seem to be one way to go about it like
in we'll try it against nipple then we
trade queens characters characters and
after d captures in c3 knight captures
you get this position let's say knight
d5 you offer a trade of knights and um
it's a it's a fine position for both
players white will always be a little
bit better as white has three pawn
islands black has four pawn island so
maybe it's gonna be a little bit easier
for white to uh to put pressure on those
pawns uh but okay here are java plays
bishop g5 and now rook to f8 now
defending the knight also aligning the
rook nicely with the queen so c3
attacking the bishop and now bishop back
to d6 and c capture on d4 now the queen
trade is no longer on the table because
you have to recapture the pawn so queen
captures on d4 and now queen to c3 again
offering a queen trade and while you
could trade it like this you don't want
to develop a white knight for free so
instead the rapper does it like this
queen d1 check only move queen e1 and
queen captures on e1 with chuck king
captures and rook to b8 so much better
than just developing um
rajabo's knight for free also you're
putting pressure on the b2 pawn and i
hope none of you are considering pawn to
b3 if pawn to b3 bishop e5 and white
resign so don't never do that so here at
knights to d2 you have to give up the b2
pawn and rapper grabs it rook captures
on b2 now knight c4 attacks the rook and
the bishop of course uh bishop to b4
this comes with check king goes back to
f1 and now knight to g4 and now look at
this incredible pressure rapport is
having on this f2 pawn
but even though it seems like rapport is
the one who's attacking rapport robert
is basically finding a unique set of
moves that uh
keep the game going for him it's just an
incredible position so here f3 chasing
away the knight also not allowing
anything to capture on f2 uh sorry uh uh
rook to f2 with czech king the g1 and
now bishop the c5 threatening all sorts
of nasty discoveries uh but here uh uh
rajabo just plays f captus and g4 it is
the only good move for white and uh well
uh you don't really see any other moves
you can't move the king so nasty
discoveries are coming uh you can only
minimize the damage so f captures on g4
and now how do you win back the material
the problem is if you play something
like rook c2 check thinking you're going
to win back the knight 93 and the knight
is defended if you attack it we're going
to defend it again rook to h3 and that's
a problem if h captures rook g3 the
knight is nicely defended uh you've got
nothing here so the only way to do it is
rook to f4 you block the bishops defense
of the e3 square and now knight to e3
we're going to play bishop captures on
e3 with check king h2 and now rook
captures on g4 attacking the the bishop
twice but also if the bishop moves we
attack the bishop on g6 so bishop
captures an e3 rook captures on g6 and
now rook h to d1 with check king to c7
and rook 8 to b1 so this is the position
we have on the board
it is uh equal material regarding pieces
but uh rapport is up to pawn so does
this mean that black is just outright
winning
not so fast because uh
rajab controls uh so many important
squares here and it's very very
difficult for a rapper to activate the
slide square bishop for the moment this
bishop is a pawn make no mistake uh and
unless you know
bishop b7 c5 happens at some point it's
not very likely that this bishop will
come alive and again the bishops are of
opposite color so it's basically like
one player is up a piece if your bishop
is doing nothing so bishop to b7 trying
to activate it somehow but now bishop to
c5 blocking the c5 pawn also putting
pressure on the rook rook the e8 now
with ideas of starting to push the past
e pawn but now bishop to d6 with check
king c8 only move for black that doesn't
lose and now bishop e5
preventing the e pawn from being pushed
and now you are controlling all of the
squares here you control this you
control this you control this this this
you control this with the bishop this uh
so the black king has no squares and if
a check happens that will be checkmate
let's uh let's say try something like
bishop here this is checkmate so you
can't do that so here uh rook the g4
rapport goes after the h4 pawn it's
undefended and it does come with check
but this move allows at a job of the
seize the moment and play rook to f1
which is not winning in itself but you
have to thread very carefully here and
c5 is a move you have to play you have
to absolutely open up this diagonal
but rapport says but i could capture on
h4 it does come with checks so there's
always time to play c5 so i'm gonna do
that uh rook captures an h4 and now king
to g1 and here we have rook to e4 going
after the bishop and now the problem is
the position is completely winning for
rajab however he only has uh about i
believe three and a half or maybe four
minutes on the clock and he needs to
make
two more moves to reach down control so
it's incredibly important to make the
the right move uh but if you don't find
it
then you will squander your winning
chances so feel free to pause the video
here don't use more than four minutes
while i give you a couple of seconds
have at it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well uh pretty pretty brilliant idea and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is bishop back to h2 this is
the only winning move and now that you
see it of course you believe it and you
understand why this is so uh this was
not played in the game in the game uh
rajabo just went for rook to f7 and he
traded the bishops which is a crime
against chess you do not trade this
bishop for this bishop this bishop is a
pawn this bishop is a dragon that uh
uh i i i
the this this move was played uh
strictly due to due to time trouble but
also because rajabov did not feel he had
winning chances because rajabo is down
three pawns uh so unless he's winning
he's definitely losing this uh but the
point is after bishop to h2 uh there is
no defense against rook to f7 now that's
the point if if you try e5 to block the
bishop's diagonal uh then again we just
bring the rook to f7 and how are you
defending your bishop you can't if rook
to a8 we just play rook to a7 and we
capture the bishop on the next move
there's no defending this you can't move
the king there's nothing you can play
here and on the other hand after bishop
to h2 let's say you played this the
prevent rook to f7 now you allow rook f8
to check which is kind of worse rook f8
check you have to move away from the
bishop as this is covered by the bishop
or dark square bishop of course so you
have to play king to d7
and you get rook captures here with
checkmate so that th that's the problem
uh but arjaba missed this he played rook
to f7 and now he gives up his dragon
bishop for the pawn bishop and that's
just not uh not not a good trait so real
captures through captures here and here
after rook the b5 uh uh upon reaching
time control so this is mu 40 it was in
this position that rajab and rapport
agreed to a draw as now there really is
nothing more to be done here the
position is uh is an objective draw and
of course they both know it now they
have time to uh see it and uh that
that's it
so really a tough break for a job of who
who misses this brilliant win the
problem is even though rapper is up
three pawns uh the the two white rooks
are too active of course you're not
going to trade you're going to play some
like czech king b8 you're going to
capture this pawn now you're attacking
this point you're attacking this pawn
and slowly but surely you will win the
back for example rook to b7 we're going
to avoid the rook trait and after rook
rook to a7 it seems like you've defended
everything and the problem is uh the
rooks are still too active or even king
to a7 if you want to keep the rook a
little bit more active we're going to
play rook to d1 get the rook to d6 and
let's say e5 rook to d6 we go after the
a6 pawn there's no defending it you're
going to play some like a5 or move the
king we're going to give this checking
bead rook captures on a5 so the pawns
are slowly uh going down one by one now
black is only up one pawn uh which with
the two very active white rooks is of
course a draw
so yeah tough break for uh for a job of
uh really really a nice one after rookie
four so uh rapport gave him the chance
by going for this pawn grab if it works
of course he's winning but if it doesn't
it seems that rajabov has either a win
or or plenty of force draws but here
yeah just bishop to h2 the only move
that uh wins the game uh the you can't
play bishop to d6 it seems like it's the
same you know it keeps the same diagonal
but the problem is you allow rook to d8
to come with tempo on h2 nothing can
touch the bishop and here you just don't
have it if you bishop h2 now now you can
play rookie to d4 and that's it if rook
to f7 we can just block this rook here
and now you're just up to too many pawns
you're winning the game
uh so really a one in a once in a
lifetime opportunity for a job of a but
he misses it and uh well uh uh a nicely
nicely for draw but that's the problem
you don't get additional time until you
reach a move 40.
uh so that that's uh you know uh
that's something that always you have to
keep in mind uh but yeah you guys uh
mentioned that you would like to see the
standings more often so not a problem
here are the settings i even enjoy
showing the stains very much so you know
if you guys wanted the standings every
video i would be happy to do it uh so
here are the standings uh yanni pomnishi
still leading the tournament after that
brilliant victory with four and a half
points fabiano caruana four points
hikaru kamura in the rihad rapport with
three points with two and a half points
at a job of the english and young [ __ ]
of duda and in last place for the moment
with two points uh alireza firuja so
we'll see how the tournament continues
uh this is i believe so far everyone is
incredibly impressed with the games with
the fighting spirit of the players it's
not like we have like three boring games
[Music]
and four draws all together in one day
you know with maybe one fighting draw
like uh everything is just flying uh
everywhere pieces are are
being demolished and uh so many winning
chances that are not uh uh you know
utilized so it's just an incredible
tournament uh so yeah once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it and some
footage and some photos understanding so
yeah there's that i would like to
thank derek booker vocal hyder go fabi
uh and uh i would like to thank dermot
and fergus from david avika sony iran
urban and hans anderson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it you can see
that ryan urban is a true chess fan as
by the amount to donate it he he really
knows his chest
but yeah as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day